Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Vous êtes prêts ?
Faites vos jeux !
Rien ne va plus.
Si vous avez 18 ans ou plus,
vous avez peut-être déjà joué
à la roulette dans un vrai casino.
Avec les machines à sous
et le poker, elle fait partie des jeux
les plus populaires de ces établissements.
Mais savez-vous qui l'a inventée et comment
gagner à tous les coups ou presque ?
Pour le savoir, direction l'atelier.
Si je vous demande de me citer une ville
qui vous fait penser aux casinos,
il y a de fortes chances
que vous me répondiez
Las Vegas, c'est la Mecque du jeu.
Cette ville du Nevada
en compte aux alentours de 120.
Toutefois, Vegas, comme on dit,
n'abrite pas le plus grand casino du monde.
Il s'agit du Venetian
qui se trouve à Macao, en Chine.
Cet établissement, tenez-vous bien,
possède 3000 machines à sous,
870 tables de poker, 3000 chambres,
24 bars-restaurants et une capacité
d'accueil de 15000 personnes.
La France n'est pas mal lotie
dans le genre.
Elle compte 203 casinos exactement,
les deux plus célèbres
étant ceux de Deauville en Normandie,
et Enghien-les-Bains, près de Paris.
Je parie que je vais encore perdre.
Encore perdu !
C'est à Napoléon Iᵉʳ que nous devons
l'arrivée des premiers casinos en France.
Au début du XIXᵉ siècle,
le pays fait face à une grave
crise économique.
Pour renflouer les caisses,
l'Empereur a alors l'idée,
en 1806,
de créer des établissements de jeux.
Enfin, de les autoriser,
car ils existent déjà, mais clandestinement.
Il peut ainsi prélever
de lourdes taxes sur les gains.
Ces casinos sont installés loin des villes
pour des raisons d'éthique.
À l'époque,
on parle plutôt de morale.
À un moment où la misère touche une part
importante de la population française,
Napoléon veut protéger les plus pauvres en
leur évitant de dilapider leurs maigres revenus.
Pari gagnant pour l'Empereur :
ces établissements connaissent
un vif succès.
Mais 30 ans plus tard, en 1836,
une nouvelle loi interdit purement
et simplement les jeux de hasard
sur le sol français.
À cause de la morale, justement.
Ils sont accusés
de pervertir la population.
Il faut attendre 1907 pour qu'ils
soient à nouveau autorisés, à condition
qu'ils se situent dans des villes classées
comme station balnéaire, station thermale
ou station climatique,
et uniquement en période de cure.
Mais pourquoi ?
Officiellement, l'idée
est d'enrichir ces petites stations
qui commencent à attirer des clients
de plus en plus fortunés.
Officieusement, l'objectif
est une nouvelle fois de désengorger
le circuit des jeux clandestins
qui sévit à Paris à cette époque.
Et en 1919, on interdit carrément
l'installation de casinos
à moins de 100 kilomètres autour de Paris.
Seule exception : Enghien-les-Bains,
dans le département du Val-d'Oise,
qui obtient une dérogation en 1931.
Des années plus tard, en 1988,
la loi permet enfin la création de casinos
dans des villes qui ne sont pas
nécessairement en bord de mer ou d'un lac,
à condition
qu'elles comptent plus de 500000 habitants
et qu'elles soient classées
"station touristique".
C'est pour cette raison
qu'aujourd'hui, en France,
on trouve des casinos dans des villes
comme Bordeaux, Lille ou Lyon
et dans 198 autres communes.
Dans tous ces casinos, on l'a dit,
l'un des jeux les plus populaires,
c'est la roulette.
Rien ne va plus !
La règle est assez simple :
il s'agit de deviner
sur quelle case va s'arrêter
une bille qu'on lance
dans le cylindre de la roulette.
Il y a 36 cases, 18 rouges,
18 noires, plus une 37ème,
la case 0 qui n'est ni rouge ni noire.
Vous pouvez miser
soit sur un chiffre : 7, 8, 18
comme vous voulez,
sur une couleur : rouge ou noir.
Vous pouvez aussi miser sur la nature
d'un chiffre : pair ou impair,
ou soit sur un groupe de chiffres
et de nombres.
De 1 à 18, vous misez sur "manque",
de 19 à 36, vous misez sur "passe".
Lorsque le croupier annonce
"Faites vos jeux",
vous devez poser vos jetons, autrement dit,
vos mises, sur les cases de votre choix.
Le 7, par exemple. Rouge, manque,
pair.
Vous avez
encore le temps de changer d'avis
et de les déplacer
jusqu'à ce qu'il lance : "Rien ne va plus !"
Il jette la bille dans la roulette.
Quand elle s'arrête, la couleur
et le numéro gagnant sont dévoilés
et le joueur est fixé sur son sort.
Côté gain, la règle est assez simple :
en fonction du risque pris par le joueur,
la récompense varie.
Par exemple,
si vous misez sur un seul chiffre, donc
une case sur les 37 possibles,
vous prenez un gros risque.
Vous emportez 35 fois la mise.
Autrement dit, si vous avez misé
1€ sur le 7, vous empochez 35€.
À l'inverse,
si vous misez sur une couleur : noir
ou rouge,
vous avez une chance sur deux de gagner.
Le risque est donc plus faible
et le gain aussi.
Vous doublez votre mise.
Pour 1€ misé sur le rouge,
si le rouge sort, vous empochez 2€.
Mais le hasard est-il
le seul facteur pour gagner ?
Eh bien, pas forcément.
Alors bien sûr,
il n'existe aucune méthode infaillible
pour gagner à tous les coups.
Vous pensez bien que si c'était le cas,
les casinos mettraient rapidement la clé
sous la porte.
Pour augmenter ses chances de gagner,
on peut utiliser les mathématiques.
Des maths...
C'est vraiment pas mon jour de chance !
Rassurez-vous,
pas besoin d'avoir fait maths sup-maths spé.
Il suffit de se concentrer
et de faire fonctionner sa mémoire.
En jouant à la roulette,
si vous pariez sur un numéro unique,
la table comportant des numéros
allant de 1 à 36 plus le 0,
vous avez donc 37 résultats possibles.
Dans ce cas de figure, statistiquement,
vos chances de l'emporter sont de
2,7%.
Puisque j'exprime les chances de gagner
en pourcentage,
le calcul est simple :
il suffit de diviser 100 par 37.
Si vous misez sur deux numéros maintenant,
vos chances de l'emporter
passent à 5,4% et ainsi de suite.
En partant de ce constat,
vous pouvez employer des méthodes simples
pour augmenter vos chances
de gagner sans tricher.
Alors, il existe plusieurs techniques.
Je ne vais pas toutes vous les présenter.
Il faudrait plusieurs vidéos pour cela.
Nous allons donc nous concentrer
sur celle qui devrait
vous permettre d'augmenter vos chances
de gagner à la roulette.
Elle découle d'une logique mathématique
bien connue, celle d'un mathématicien
italien du XIIᵉ siècle,
Leonardo Fibonacci.
Avant de commencer, une petite précision :
cette méthode ne fonctionne
que si l'on mise sur des cases simples :
pair, impair, rouge, noir, passe, manque.
Ça ne fonctionne pas
lorsque l'on mise sur un numéro.
Regardez bien ce tableau sur lequel figure
une suite de chiffres
et de nombres apparemment sans rapport
les uns avec les autres.
Pourtant, il s'agit d'une suite logique.
Chaque chiffre correspond
à la somme des deux précédents.
0 + 1 = 1,
1 + 1 = 2,
1 + 2 = 3,
2 + 3 = 5, etc.
Mais quel rapport avec la roulette ?
Imaginez que vous pariez 1€
sur un numéro pair. Deux solutions possibles :
le numéro qui tombe est pair :
vous gagnez, il est impair : vous perdez.
Eh bien, c'est là
que Fibonacci va nous aider.
Il faut miser en suivant
la suite logique du mathématicien italien.
Cette suite commence avec 0 et 1,
la première mise sera donc de 0 + 1
un euro.
Si vous perdez, la mise suivante sera de
1 + 1 = 2€. Si vous perdez à nouveau,
la mise suivante est de 1 + 2
3€ et la mise encore suivante
sera de 5€.
Si à ce moment-là, vous gagnez,
vous devez retirer les deux derniers
numéros de la suite, à savoir le 3
et le 2, et reprendre à ce niveau.
La mise qui suit sera de 1 + 1 = 2 €.
Concrètement, la méthode de Fibonacci
demande aux joueurs d'augmenter
leur mise en cas de perte
et de diminuer en cas de gain.
L'intérêt de cette méthode, c'est
de permettre aux joueurs de commencer
par de faibles mises et d'éviter de perdre
beaucoup d'argent en cas de défaite.
Mais je vous le rappelle,
la roulette reste avant tout
un jeu de hasard et le seul moyen
de gagner à tous les coups
ou presque, c'est de tricher ou de trouver
une faille dans les règles du casino.
Et à ce petit jeu,
certains ont réussi un véritable
coup de maître il y a quelques années.
L'histoire se déroule en 2004
dans un casino londonien.
Trois joueurs,
une femme et deux hommes, bénéficient
d'une chance insolente à la roulette
deux soirs de suite.
Le premier jour,
ils raflent l'équivalent de 145000€
avant de faire sauter la banque
le lendemain, en empochant
1,7 milliond'euros.
Du jamais vu.
Persuadés
qu'ils ont utilisé une martingale,
c'est-à-dire, une stratégie qui permet
d'augmenter les chances de gagner,
les propriétaires du casino
portent plainte auprès de Scotland Yard,
qui place aussitôt
les suspects en détention provisoire.
Les joueurs sont interrogés
et au bout de quelques heures,
ils finissent par avouer.
Oui, ils ont triché.
Mais aussi incroyable
que cela puisse paraître,
ils ne seront pas condamnés
par la justice britannique.
Non ! Mais dis-moi comment ils ont fait !
En fait, ces petits malins
avaient trafiqué leurs téléphones.
Ils analysaient la vitesse à laquelle
la bille était lancée par le croupier.
Puis, ils calculaient le chiffre
sur lequel elle allait s'arrêter
avec une faible marge d'erreur.
Grâce à ce système,
ils ont fait passer leur chance de gagner
d'une sur 37 à seulement une sur six.
La prouesse est d'autant plus incroyable
qu'à cette époque, nous sommes trois ans
avant la sortie du tout
premier modèle de smartphone.
Non, mais ça se fait pas !
- C'est de la triche.
- Attends !
L'histoire n'est pas terminée.
À l'issue de neuf mois d'enquête,
bien que l'arnaque
soit clairement avérée, les trois suspects
sont finalement relaxés.
On va même leur restituer leurs gains.
En effet,
les juges britanniques déclarent que
cette martingale est parfaitement légale.
En 2004, la réglementation en vigueur
interdit seulement d'intervenir
sur le fonctionnement physique
de l'appareil, de ralentir
ou d'accélérer de quelque façon
que ce soit, la vitesse de la boule.
Or, ce n'était pas le cas.
Je tiens quand même à mettre en garde
celles et ceux qui seraient tentés
de reproduire la même chose :
la législation en vigueur dans notre pays
interdit formellement l'usage de matériel
qui permettrait
de remettre en cause le facteur de hasard
dans l'enceinte des casinos.
Par ailleurs,
depuis cette affaire,
à chaque début de partie, quel que soit
le jeu, le croupier demande désormais
d'éteindre les smartphones.
Enfin, retenez bien que tricher au casino
peut coûter très cher.
En 2018,
des petits malins qui avaient découvert
une faille dans les roulettes électroniques
installées à Enghien ont été condamnés
pour escroquerie en bande organisée.
Des peines de prison ferme de 3 à 6 mois
ont été prononcées, ainsi que des amendes
allant jusqu'à 7000€.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Avant de vous quitter,
je tiens quand même à vous rappeler
que le jeu, c'est comme l'alcool,
la drogue ou le tabac, ça peut très vite
devenir addictif, alors surtout, restez vigilants.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez
pas à laisser un commentaire
et à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait. À très bientôt !